and now
with uh you know your transitioning
seems to be as like a full-time artist
now
how often do you still like oh that's my
whole life so you don't engage in that
kind of
like you know like obviously you're
still tapped in on your youtube with
your fans because they said yeah yeah i
love my
supporters but as far as like my family
your focus
is totally fully made yeah 100 percent
artists man
come on yo you got to read me listen man
i i this i
we i i'll be having this discussion with
a lot of people because i remember being
in here when he was recording once and i
was like
oh this was actually like writing his
own [ __ ] and it's dope like
at the end of the day like i've also
been in here with youtubers
who are [ __ ] horrible who
need writers or they they really just
need to do some other [ __ ]
yeah because the music ain't for them
but you like bro your [ __ ] is
i've heard a lot of your unreleased [ __ ]
and it's very very good man so props to
you for
for for figuring that out um i got some
[ __ ] coming but you definitely
are very um you take offense
to people calling you a youtuber turned
rapper right
or to kind of putting that youtube
rapper like that
i know there was like a little uh you
gotta stop saying that around me man
that's what i'm saying
so you know i i appreciate why i offend
you because you're like yo look i'm
really an artist
yeah um but but is it is it kind of
unfair to get mad at people if they say
that
because i know you kind of had a little
spat with adam 22 at least yeah
you're not a fan of atom22 nah i'm i
think adam 22 is just he knows
the position he knows his his power
so he feel like he could just say
whatever but in person nick cool as hell
no he's a great guy different he get on
the internet he talks so much [ __ ] in
person
what's up bro so it's like like [ __ ]
just go here but the youtube rapper
title is something that you do not [ __ ]
with i mean
to be honest i really don't give a [ __ ]
i'll just be meme in myself like i just
missed
saying i'm a rapper that's just one of
the things i've been saying now like
it's just a part of my um
what you call it i don't know
strategy i guess yeah look man you like
you said you got the you got this [ __ ]
figured out
for better or worse yeah i mean [ __ ]
already knew our [ __ ] knew i've been
hard that's the thing
everybody knew i've been hard it was
just about
for me it's literally just association
so when somebody see me with another
that's why i knew moonwalking was gonna
blow up i'm like
damn this [ __ ] blew and this [ __ ] blue
face snapped on that [ __ ]
he was on beat he was going bonkers
he hadn't had to be nudged or nothing
that was straight he was on beat yeah
took him like 20 minutes you ran through
that [ __ ] right so i'm like okay
back this thing he's like shoot the
video i'm like [ __ ] back
because you know coming off of youtube
as a as an
artist they probably would look at
somebody like me coming off of youtube
is like i don't really want to associate
with that [ __ ] like that because
i don't want to be in that lane you know
there's a stigma that comes from that
yeah so blueface showed me love and [ __ ]
so i was like back you know what i mean
real [ __ ] whoop
so we shot the video bomb bop and it was
just
i already knew it was going to blow up
right it was just about
who was going to be the person to give
me that shot you know what i mean
do you remember uh when you first found
out the song was on rap caviar because
that's kind of like
that's like that yeah that's that career
changer that that's like at the top
it was like the top of rap caveat that's
that was it right there rap caviar shout
out to them [ __ ]
yeah like when you shout out do you
remember when you found out that it was
on it because
it wasn't like it was just on there
notification this [ __ ] was like at the
top
she went to gmail came straight to my
gmail